savoir news morricone comment vous
travaillez avec sergio leone et comment
vous viennent ces musiques
je vais demander à sergio gobbi de
traduire quoi l'ère laporte en concert
jazz lyonnais n'est lavaur et comme
expiration et le thema musicale et
libyenne
donc quand nous l'avons à porto gami
chips et du carré saint louis fait de
l'observation et hauts responsables ou
en achetant nos subventions pour utah
dans le travail s'adapte à tout d'abord
un rapport d'amitié et de lucidité il
prit fait des propositions certes sur
phoebé observation ils échangent leurs
idées et j'arrive résultats par exemple
l'harmonica là au début et lâches ils te
présenter des listes roaming ti musicale
et non une colle casoli à la zone
copions on en est aux cris de la musica
vers allemand haut de gamme à
l'harmonica et raj inscrits c'est déjà
prévu d'un découpage mais qui avoue
tholy des inserts jo les anonymes n'ont
ni idées ni celles de l'ennemi inscrits
à la musique avec l'harmonie cam à
l'harmonica rassoul que beyoncé aviva
jack la tour et de retourner en studio
harmonic léger disait jeudi à nyon que
je voulais en musique que de mort si
vous voulez et alors je fais jouer cette
cette console je fais jouer la malle
harmonique
il m'a donné un thème si vous voulez que
c'est un thème initial par les définitif
est après nous avons essayé jusqu'à en
avoir les thèmes que vous avez écouté
un thème de début et puis quel musicien
et il me recon musicien classique au
départ et j'ai dit nous assiste elle est
classique au moderne et strano rio au
fait de l'histoire dit série signée
quindi polyhandicap travers la musique
aussi d'état s'est gouré la commande
il ya bien en tout cas c est rien car
gaulle a dit shin 70 hommes existe a dit
cinéma d'hévéa sur le terrain qu'avec
l'expérience a pu leur galop cible
inquest rio d'orly tôt 10/10 au
classicisme à voter oui au départ il a
il a fait des études très sérieux en
tant que musicien classique
dans tous les cas pour lui toute musique
est très sérieuse à une fois havas fait
ses études il est revenu au niveau le
plus bas
et c est là travail et donc pour le
cinéma la musique de film est une
musique sérieuse de la pauvre il libère
on demand qui l'a pas pris ma seconde et
moult au cinéma qui volent et où la
musique à l'appui leur grande expérience
possible les queens bien possible
l'unita distillés comme celle de la
musique classique musonia ce drame était
seraient prêtes à servir
il filmait le public commun et public au
sein des primes du christ on compromet
se réunissent à des assauts de
manchester
oui il dit que l'unité l'unité de la
musique de film ne peut pas avoir la
même la même unité gras musique
classique parce que ça doit doit
interpréter une heure donc c'est surtout
une sorte d'assimilation entre les et du
metteur en scène et se mettre au service
du métro sexe il ne peut pas y avoir une
unité de style à travers toutes les
musiques de fait s'il n'y avait pas eu
sergio leone est ce que morricone aurait
été un compositeur connu c'est celle de
léo et non faussée exister tant les
célèbres du métatron logistique aux usa
et qui ne sont pas que la saq dit qu'il
a fait de musiques de film ander de lui
très jolie dans le sens lindo in common
que des bons temps sergio leone et kindy
fait des bonds molto probio robert louis
est pas une particule à réal source
style tu es et où nos dépôts qui suit
force est l'unique on peut très
dirigiste a que six conditions d'accueil
sans condition y voit les prix risquent
à tout le monde
il a indiqué qu'en dit qu' il va
beaucoup à céret on n'est pas ce que
c'est peut-être le seul maître hassen
qui conditionne à tel point le musicien
pour lui permettre de s'exprimer ce
pensionnat trafic totalement
[Musique]